[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique où nous
parlons aujourd'hui de la première année
de nous députés à l'assemblée nationale
et pour dresser un bilan de ses 12
premiers mois de travail de députés de
jeunes députés avec nous sur ce plateau
tout d'abord fanette charvier député la
république en marche du doubs elle a 33
ans avant d'être élu à l'assemblée
nationale elle gérait la plateforme
téléphonique de la ceppm la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie à besançon
face à elle
yanbu cas députés les républicains du
territoire de belfort lui il a 30 ans
son parcours professionnel entre autres
commerciales et aussi et surtout
assistant parlementaire de damien meslot
député les républicains du territoire de
belfort alors je précise que yann
bouchard a vu son élections de juin
dernier
invalide et puis il a été réélu quelques
mois plus tard
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez commenter
cette émission grâce au hashtag dit mme
paul fc à hashtag dit mme paul fc comme
dimanche en politique franche comté
alors je me tourne tout d'abord vers
fanette charvier la première question
est pour vous
comment allez vous est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas trop crevé c'est pourquoi je
dis ça parce qu'il paraît que vous avez
un rythme de travail insupportables je
je je sais effectivement pourquoi vous
dites ça c'est vrai que certaines voix
se sont élevées quant à l'organisation
de nos humeurs vous vous êtes fatigué ou
pas moi non
vous vous tenez le choc non non non ah
oui pourquoi je dis ça parce que pour
une fois quand mam françois de rugy
le président de l'assemblée nationale et
jean luc mélenchon le député de la
france a soumis sont d'accord le rythme
de travail est trop dur
françois de rugy dit ce n'est plus
possible c'est le patron qui le dit et
jean luc mélenchon lui parle carrément
d'horaires intenable il paraît que vous
travaillez jusqu'à 80 heures en séance
par semaine jusqu'à dix sept jours
d'affilée
c'est normal ça alors effectivement on a
eu une grosse séquence parce que on a eu
à étudier des textes conséquent
moi je pense que c'est normal je pense
effectivement fin c'est normal en tout
cas c'est normal qu'on soit présent
quand il ya besoin
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas on n'a
pas toujours siéger les week-ends ça
nous est arrivé une fois sur rasé
l'immigration là c'est vrai que ça fait
plusieurs week-ends d'affilée
donc je pense que c'est ça que signale
françois de rugy et d'autres avec lui
c'est surtout qu'on n'était pas prévenue
à l'avancé et c'est cette incertitude
sur est-ce qu'on siège le week-end ou
pas qui à mon sens pause pose problème
y'a de boucard alors vous vous tenez le
seul coupable
le rythme est soutenu mais je trouve que
ce débat est un peu indécent honnêtement
quand on a la chance de servir son pays
quand on a la chance de défendre ses
convictions
quand on a la chance d'être député
nation je crois qu'on a pas de se
plaindre je visitais il ya deux jours un
régiment d'infanterie avec des
militaires il attendait pas de leur
député qui se plaignent je pense aux
aides soignantes qui font en ce moment
en grève
elles ont certainement plus de raison
que nous ne se plaint une chose que ce
débat est indécent
on a la chance l'un et l'autre mais en
dessin 77 de représenter la nation
et je crois qu'il faut se mettre au
travail arrêtées ceci étant il ya quand
même une vraie question est là derrière
est ce que vous l'avez vous la fais de
bien la loi finalement au bout derrière
une question là derrière c'est que
l'assemblée le parlement est à la
charrette du gouvernement qui nous
impose un rythme qui est dit
d'efficacité moi je pense que la loi il
faut la faire bien plutôt que de la
faire dit le vrai débat est là parce que
pour le moment la loi on l'a fait vite
je suis pas certain que des sujets aussi
fondamentaux que certains qui passe à 3
heures du matin ou à une heure du matin
soit effectivement bien traités alors
vous la fait de bien ou mal cette loi et
pour des lui regarder alors la loi je
pense qu'elle est elle est faite elle
est bien faite et et on ne se plaint pas
d'ailleurs de la charge de travail
simplement françois de rugy c'est ce
qu'il a dit quand il a fait remarquer
c'est que effectivement dans
l'organisation des débats il serait
quand même plutôt sympa nous prévenir
quand est-ce qu'on siège quand mais
voilà quand le jeudi on ne sait pas si
finalement on va siéger le vendredi le
samedi ou le dimanche ça implique aussi
que derrière en circonscription quand on
a des rendez vous etc
on ne peut pas en annuler au dernier
moment et c'est parce qu'il faut pas ce
condo on se doit aussi d'être dans
l'hémicycle pour voter la loi et pour
bien la faire alors justement fenêtre
chervier vous a occupé donc le poste de
député de la première circonscription du
doubs
on vous voit pratiquement pas à besançon
pratiquement pas dans votre
circonscription
alors comment vous vous organisez vous
êtes toujours à paris jamais jamais ici
donc pourtant je suis je suis dans ma
circonscription je rencontre toutes les
personnes qui ont demandé à me
rencontrer il y en a eu beaucoup
notamment au début parce que je faisais
pas de politique avant et donc on ne me
connaissaient pas donc il ya eu toutes
toutes ces sollicitations pour faire
connaissance
non j'y suis j'ai organisé des ateliers
thématiques des ateliers citoyens sur la
navette parlementaire sur la mobilité du
quotidien sur l'apprentissage sur la
future loi pacte je vise c'est quand
même comment vous organisez votre temps
vous passez combien de jours à paris
combien de jours a besoin alors en
principe je pars le lundi soir
mais je dis bien en principe ça peut
m'arriver de partir avant et je reviens
en principe le jeudi soir mais encore
une fois ça peut m'arriver de revenir
après ses fonctions d'organisation et on
a des semaines où on siège du mardi au
jeudi il ya des semaines où on siège du
lundi au dimanche
dimanche encore d'après donc voilà en
termes d'organisation c'est vrai que ça
pose problème le fait qu' on ne sache
pas beaucoup d'émoi vous n'êtes pas une
visibilité sur la profondeur de l'agenda
vous avez été surnommée la député
fantôme mais vous récusez ce terme je
récuse complètement ce terme je suis en
circonscription et tout ce que j'ai pu
rencontrer partout où je suis allé on
pourra vous le dire il ya tout car vous
vous organisez comment moi je passe
entre 3 et 3 jours et demi à paris par
semaine après ça dépend des textes
effectivement sur l immigration l'a fait
sept jours d'affilée sur élan et lancer
la loi la loi logement dans le logement
ces logements
il ya eu aussi la loi agriculture et
alimentation je crois qu'il fait des
gros morceaux
c'est important qu'on puisse être à la
fois dans l'hémicycle à la fois ancien
de conscription et c'est ce qui nous
différencie
parfois certains députés la république
en marche c'est que moi j'estime qu'il
faut qu'on soit très présent
circonscription pour rencontrer nos
citoyens et pour faire remonter au
parlement aussi ce qui ne va pas ce qui
ne va pas sur le terrain il ya un
collègue de l'âme charlier qui disait
l'autre fois vivement qui est 30%
députés en moins on sera quitte comme ça
d'inaugurer les tôles et tournoi de
pétanque et d'aller d'aller aux
manifestations des anciens combattants
parce que ce n'est pas le rôle d'un
député bah si c'est aussi le rôle d'un
député
parce que quand on est sur le terrain à
la rencontre de nos concitoyens c'est
comme ça que derrière on fait la loi
efficacement en faisant remonter
rés
le monde les problèmes du thym à paris
alors vous j'ai vu dans un hebdomadaire
que vous faites partie de ceux qu'on
appelle les sales gosses de l'assemblée
nationale d'hier les députés trentenaire
qui sont là aussi pour on va dire
chahuté la majorité ça c'est aussi le
rôle d'un député si les trains sales
gosses c'est à dire au gouvernement
quand on n'est pas d'accord avec lui tu
étais brillamment bruyamment venant me
vous regarderez match ou pas bruyant
dans l'hémicycle pour prendre il voulait
prendre les comptes-rendus il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas de petits objectifs que je
n'en serai pas mon coeur par vous savez
vous avez des collègues aussi vos
copains à vous sur les bancs de
l'assemblée qui ont peu près le même âge
que vous qui chahutent mais ça a
toujours été ça toujours été le cas je
crois que ça fait aussi partie du ca
fait aussi partie du parlement mais si
être un sale gosse et défendre les
intérêts de notre mort de notre région
et de mon département à l'international
alors je leur ont dit parfaitement de
fermer au casque si vous l'entendez vous
des fois c'est un sale gosse ou pas ou
savoir monsieur bouquin non je pense pas
je pense je pense pas l'avoir entendu en
tout cas par contre oui il c'est vrai
qu'il a certains de ses collègues qui se
manifestent parfois bruyamment voire
très bruyamment
moi je pense pas que ce soit le rôle
d'un député que de perturber les débats
des débats qui se passe habituellement
bien on peut ne pas être d'accord mais
on doit laisser s'exprimer les gens et
et hurler parfois parce que c'est le mot
hurler pour couvrir les mots d'un autre
député
voilà je cours pour moi c'est pas on
fait pas preuve d' exemple des gants
n'est pas exemplaire et pourtant c'est
ce que doit être un député s'il doit
être exemplaire et recouvrir les mots
d'un autre député qui s'exprime pour moi
ça n'est pas qu'en l'occurrence je peux
me permettre c'est pendant les questions
au gouvernement qui sont comme un
exercice pour ça qu'ils ont le courage
de les regarder sur la chaîne
parlementaire qui comme un exercice qui
est extrêmement aseptisé et finalement
où on a un député qui pose une question
et la nouveauté c'est toujours à droite
est indemne et la nutrition un nouveau
texte gouvernement c'est qu'ils ne
répondent pas à la question c'est qui
font un développement vagues pendant
deux minutes sur autre chose reprenant
pendant une minute la question et penser
à un député de répliques en marche qui
pose une question souvent l'impression
qu'elle a été écrite par le ministre
lui-même der le ministre général
commence par remercier le député pour la
question je rappelle que leur un des
rôles du parlement c'est de contrôler
l'action du gouvernement
donc quand on estime que le parlement
que le gouvernement parle on ne répond
pas à l'assemblée nationale je pense
qu'il est sain que les députés le signal
au ministre alors peut-être que parfois
il ya quelques excès j'en conviens
bien naturellement mais je crois qu'il
est sain que le parlement ne soit pas
trop aseptisé alors on a parlé donc de
votre bannière de fonctionner des uns et
des autres ont maintenant on va aborder
le fond de l'action politique de ce
gouvernement et de la de l'assemblée
nationale une question aux fenêtres
service qu'il reste encore un petit peu
de gauche dans l'action politique d'
emmanuel macron puisque je cite donc un
député de votre majorité la république
en marche annoncée un socialiste y en a
dans vos rangs qui dit qu avec emmanuel
macron on à la politique d'immigration
d'hortefeux la politique économique de
sarkozy et la politique environnementale
d'edf
le constat semble amer c'est c'est son
opinion c'est pas la mienne moi je pense
qu'on n'a pas assez
voilà on porte peut-être pas assez
toutes les mesures sociales que prend
que prend le gouvernement
et puis moi je suis pas dans une loi de
droite ou une droit de gauche je couche
juge complètement dépassé j'ai
complètement dépassés ce cette
opposition
quelque part quand on agit pour le
travail on agit voilà notre priorité
c'est le travail et le travail c'est un
bel et bien un rempart contre toutes les
inégalités qui puisse exister et en
termes de mesures sociales et bien il y
en a un certain nombre et je crois qu'on
va développer on les oublie souvent
alors jean françois copé bouquet qui
aidé dans vos rangs dit ce président est
un président de droite qu'on attendait
pas vous vous la met bien ce président
macron de droite pour une fois je suis
d'accord et roland charlier
je crois que monsieur macro on n'est ni
de droite ni de droite il ya de
l'affichage parfois dans les discours et
nous prenons un exemple important sur la
loi l'asile l'immigration
c'est une loi qui est tout sauf de droit
de se nouer n'a strictement rien dedans
en fait en réalité on ne trouve pas de
dans la solution pour expulser ceux qui
sont en situation irrégulière sur le sol
français ce qui représente une menace
pour la nation et qui sont sur le
territoire il n'ya dans ce texte rien du
tout pour le faire il ya beaucoup
d'affichage
il ya des ministres qui viennent de
droite il faut le reconnaître dont le
premier d'entre eux mais on a d'abord et
vous l'avez rappelé une majorité de
parlementaires qui sont soit de la
société civile soient côte ils ont déjà
fait de la politique exclusivement des
anciens socialistes il ya aucun ancien
des députés débattent dans les 350
députés à l'appui que marche alors vous
parlez de justice sociale qui passe déjà
par le travail
gérard darmanin a déclaré il ya quelques
jours qu'il y a trop dette sociale trop
dette sociale est ce que ça vous choque
ou pas alors moi ça me choque pas dans
la mesure où c'est ce que vous aviez dit
votre première priorité dans votre
campagne c'était justement la justice
sociale cuir sûr que je m'interroge
comment est ce que vous y retrouver je
pense qu'il faut pas le prendre en se
disant il ya trop de dettes sociales en
termes de montants on sait pas c'est pas
une question financière simplement qu'il
y en a trop différentes
on s'y perd et moi qui connais bien ce
milieu là du social de fin du social il
ya une telle complexité aujourd'hui
devant les aides qui existent que
souvent les gens mais c'est lé mal est
grande par sa formule zetec la malade la
formule était très maladroite elle a été
comme d'habitude j'ai envie de dire
sorties sorties d'un an c'est encore la
faute des journées mais non non pas du
tout pas du tout mais simplement voilà
l'idée c'est quand même aimé c'est ce
qu'on applique en fait depuis les bus et
comment est-ce qu'on peut être plus
efficace c'est se dire qu'à un moment
donné quand on se rend compte qu'il ya
tout un tas de choses qui sont
pacifiques
as comment on fait pour les rendre plus
efficace et donc plus efficiente tout en
faisant attention mais la baisse de 5
euros des apl c'est aussi très maladroit
la de 5 euros ça correspond pas grand
chose dans les comptes de l'état et pour
les gens ça peut représenter quelque
chose quand même
la baisse de 5 euros des apl
effectivement ça a été une erreur de
communication il annonce je pense que on
était oublié d'erreur je pense qu'on
n'était pas obligé effectivement dire
courir après c'est à mettre en
perspective avec tout ce qu'on fait sur
le logement la restructuration du
logement social qui doit conduire
justement à une baisse des loyers
parce qu'aujourd'hui on se rend bien
compte que quel que soit l'argent public
qu'on met dans le logement il ya
toujours 4 millions de mal logés et
qu'en plus les loyers ne cessent
d'augmenter donc ça c'est intenable
yanbu car votre réaction ma réaction
c'est que l'exemple typique est bon le
gouvernement va faire cela effectivement
donné une baisse de loyer pour les
locataires ne serait pas supporté par
l'état elle sera supportée par les
bailleurs sociaux qu'on va mettre en
grande difficulté l'objectif c'est de
fusionner les bailleurs sociaux entre
les deux contrats un seul bailleur au
niveau franc comtois demain ce qui veut
dire qu'il y aura moins de proximité ce
qui veut dire qu'il y aura moins service
rendu au citoyen ça veut dire aussi par
exemple qu'on pourra - réhabiliter les
logements va vous me dites normes et
nous prend l'exemple du territoire de
belfort avec la réforme que vous venez
de mettre en place la capacité
d'investissement de territoire habitat
était de 20 millions d'euros en 2016
elle sera de 4 millions d'euros en 2019
ça fait 16 millions d'euros de moins qui
seront investis dans les logements donc
autant d'ailleurs pour les entreprises
locales c'est des réformes à la petite
semaine c'est des réformes à chaque fois
de petits comptables si je peux me
permettre
et dehors monsieur darmanin vous avez
pris le bon exemple parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est lui le vrai premier ministre c'est
bercy aujourd'hui qu'ils aient les
cheveux couleur c'est quelqu'un qui
gagnent reebok en main n'a fait tout à
fait c'est pas parce qu'il est chez moi
qui fais que des bonnes choses vous avez
remarqué qu' il avait franchi le rubicon
depuis et ont tout est fait aujourd'hui
à bercy sur la loi de programmation
militaire parlant qu'on a voté des
crédits qui sont pour le moment au sein
d'autres moi je m'en satisfais le vrai
problème c'est qu'on sait sans doute que
bercy va passer ils vont en enlever une
bonne partie donc on a un vrai souci là
dessus et pour le coup je jette même pas
la pyrale charlie ce que je suis pas sûr
que ni les députés ni même parfois le
premier ministre maîtrise ce genre de
choses mais le président fait tout à
bercy
j'aimerais qu'on parle d'un sujet très
franc comtois est qui
regardez par toute la france la
direction de psa à vesoul remet en cause
les 35 heures elle propose de travailler
beaucoup plus pour ne pas gagner
beaucoup plus travaillée eu pour cent
plus travail gagné 3% supplémentaires
c'est possible avec les ordonnances
travail et de macron vous bien debout
car vous applaudissez c'est bien
absolument pas qu'on puisse travailler
plus que 35 heures j'y suis totalement
favorable et ça me ferait donc des
heures supplémentaires je serais
favorable à ce que ces heures
supplémentaires soit défiscalisés dans
la droite avait que la sarkozie on a
défiscalisé les heures supplémentaires
après si l'on repasse tout sans
consensus à 39 heures payées 39 semblé
aussi mais si on travaille 39 heures on
est payé 39 heures c'est pas 39 heures
travaillées payer 33
enfin je veux dire tout le monde doit y
y tout le monde doit y trouver son
compte le patron le chef d'entreprise et
sam sam va bien mais le salarié aussi
s'ils travaillent 39 heures ils doivent
être payées 39 servi vous en pensez quoi
de cette remise en cause des 35 heures
ap ça et ailleurs moi je moi je pense
que ce qui est ce que ce que permet à
votre travail c'est un accord entre le
patronat et les syndicats donc si les
syndicats s'y opposent ça ne passera pas
tout simplement donc série ça nous
allons y arriver que vesoul
c'était le lusine du groupe où les
syndicats on va dire très contestataire
et témoins représentait est la direction
de psa n'a pas choisi ce lieu là par
hasard
donc ils ont choisi un endroit où
justement ça allait être plus facile
peut-être qu ailleurs et après encore
une fois ça ne se fera pas sans l'accord
des syndicats et donc si les syndicats
ne le veulent pas s'ils préfèrent
peut-être proposer autre chose et bien
ça ne se fera pas c'est aussi simple que
ça et vous ça vous choque pas qui est un
espèce de chantage à l'emploi alors que
le groupe se porte très bien
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment je ne sais
pas si on peut parler de chantage à
l'emploi après sur l'automobile c'est
vrai que la volonté sur ces ordonnances
travail c'est quand même de pouvoir
quand tout le monde est d'accord
adapter les règles adaptées en fait les
conditions de travail donc il faut bien
que tout le monde soit d'accord et ce à
tout le monde en est conscient
parfois ça fonctionne et on a eu deux
on a deux pauses exemple de réussite
avec des entreprises sont complètement
remis sur les rails grâce à ce ne va pas
mal c'est la dette et parfois on a
effectivement des des échecs
malheureusement mais encore une fois je
pense pas qui est le méchant patronat
d'un côté et les gentils syndicats de
l'autre voilà tout le monde se met
ensemble autour d'une table et aussi
accord il ya accord ça veut dire que
tout le monde est d'accord pour aller
dans la même direction
donc c'est négocié à l'échelle de
l'entreprise
vous êtes bien ça oui mais avec des
garde-fous puisque on a toujours des
normes sur lesquelles on ne pourra pas
revenir donc il ya quand même des
garde-fous qui sont qui seront qui sont
avec toi d'ailleurs sur laquelle on
pourrait parvenir par exemple m'a par
exemple sur les ordonnances travail pour
les négociations entre entre entre
branches il ya voilà en fonction des
branches il ya des choses sur lesquelles
on pourra pas revenir qui sont garanties
par la loi
et puis au final plus on avance et et
les syndicats encore une fois syndicats
et patronat se mettre d'accord autour
d'une table si le syndicat nestlé
syndicat majoritaire ne sont pas
d'accord pour aller dans la même
direction à ce moment là rien ne va pas
dans cette direction là et donc on se
remet autour de la table et on rediscute
dans la vie réelle madame charvier le
patron de l'usiné va dire aux syndicats
la vie réelle je la connais mais dans la
ville-etat mais dans la vie réelle de
psa à vesoul le patron de l'usiné va
dire aux syndicats écoutez si vous
ratifiez pas l'accord on va pas
remplacer tel et tel machin on va pas
garder les intérimaires c'est de ça dont
parle catherine gillet quand elle dit
qu'il est un chantage à l'emploi en fait
parce que sur tout ce que vous dites
c'est des beaux discours suis d'accord
après in fine et comment ça va se passer
à vesoul
je suis pas aussi certain que ce soit
aussi facile et aussi beaucoup le deal
et ça peut être un coin enfoncé dans la
loi des 35 heures qui est quand même une
loi emblématique en france et dont on
fête les 20 ans cette année quoi oui
c'est une l'emblématique mais les 35
heures dans un certain nombre de
branches et dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises difficile à mettre en
place et je pense qu'effectivement que
dans certains certains secteurs on
pourrait certainement gagné et que même
certains salariés demandent parfois à
pouvoir travailler au delà de 35 heures
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on puisse
conserver une certaine agilité au niveau
de l'entreprise quand il y en a besoin
quand c'est argumenté
et quand tout le monde est d'accord pour
aller dans la même direction alors sur
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
c'est boukari va être content puisque ça
fait partie
des pistes qu'on a effectivement et
qu'on souhaite pouvoir mettre en place
ce qu'on a fait beaucoup de choses pour
l'instant pour les entreprises et ça me
va bien
il faut aussi maintenant faire quelque
chose pour le pouvoir d'achat des
travailleurs et des français parce que
si on veut notamment faire baisser le
chômage et faire en sorte que le travail
paye plus que les allocations
alors peut-être que monsieur d'armes en
avait blessé les allocations vous pouvez
aussi faire en sorte que le travail paie
mieux et c'est une des mesures qui
permet de le faire et je regrette
puisque si on est d'accord je regrette
que vous n'ayez pas voter la proposition
de loi du groupe l'est républicain qu'on
a défendu au mois de mars de mémoire et
qui a été renvoyé en commission avant
même de pouvoir a débattu dans le petit
train dans le dans l'hémicycle par votre
groupe sade est servi on en discutera de
mais c'est comme intéressant d'assister
comme qu'on est un peu là à fronts
renversés à savoir que yann bout car
c'est plus à gauche que moi tu meurs
alors fans est oui j'ai jeu oui c'est
intéressant car d'écouter ce que vous
dites par rapport à ce que dit fanny
charvier fanette janvier vous avez voté
deux fois j'allais dire contre le
gouvernement et ses propositions alors
vous étiez contre la rétention des
migrants mineurs et vous avez voté pour
l'interdiction du glyphosate en
agriculture quelle a été la réaction de
richard ferrand le patron de votre
groupe vous avez été sermonné ou pas du
tout pas du tout pas du tout je suis
libre on n'a pas être sermonnés puisque
le vote d'un député lui appartient pas
trop que ça se reproduise on vous
traitera de francs 2 savez on est
toujours soit on voit comment comme le
com notre groupe et on est et on nous
traite de godillots soit on va
différemment on a le spectre de la
fronde qui s'agitent derrière donc quoi
qu'on fasse à l'embrassade d'encana a vu
justement où la fronde vient d'y figurer
social sûr mais la fronde des députés
socialistes étaient quand même c'est
aller jusqu'à ne pas renouveler la
confiance au gouvernement donc moi je
m'inscris pas dans cette
là dedans globalement sur le projet moi
je suis d'accord j'adhère au projet
c'est ce qui m'a amené à la politique
d'ailleurs donc sur le pro / sur les
projets de loi je suis d'accord je vais
aller voter c'est pas parce que j'ai pas
gain de cause sur un amendement ou
quelques amendements au sein du projet
de loi que je vais pas voter le projet
dans l'ensemble parce que le projet dans
l'ensemble va dans le bon sens après
effectivement parfois il m'arrive de ne
pas être d'accord sur les moyens à
employer pour aller dans cette même
direction qu'on souhaite tous donc il
m'est arrivé effectivement à plusieurs
reprises vie il y en a eu d'autres mais
c'est vrai que là vous avez cités les
plus emblématiques sur sur
l'interdiction de la rétention des
mineurs j'avais voté pour parce que pour
moi c'est c'est quelque chose voilà
c'est presque philosophique
j'ai un peu de mal à me dire que demain
on va pouvoir placer en centre on peut
continuer à placer en centre de
rétention des mineurs j'aurais aimé
qu'on puisse trouver des solutions et
d'ailleurs en certain nombre de députés
va s'employer à trouver des solutions
pour qu'on puisse dire au gouvernement
vous voilà on a la solution maintenant
vous pouvez plus nous nous apporter des
arguments techniques en disant que c'est
pas possible c'est possible donc faisons
le et sur le glyphosate c'est bien
c'était un engagement de campagne
je pense qu'on a des solutions
alternatives à mettre en place pour ça
que j'avais voté pour l'interdiction du
glyphosate dans trois ans il ya de beaux
gars sur la rétention des migrants
mineurs et sur le glyphosate vous avez
voté comment parce que j'étais en
désaccord avec madame charrier sur les
deux cadors sur le deuxième je fais le
signe du temps d'expliquer comme elle
sur la première la difficulté c'est que
si on veut pas mettre en rétention les
mineurs étrangers avec leurs familles de
facto connaître la famille est de facto
il reste in fine est toujours sur le
territoire
donc on ne peut pas procédé aux
reconduites à la frontière quand ils
sont en situation régulière donc là on
adhère
et puis après l'interdiction du qu'il
faisait la fnsea a déclaré que interdire
le glyphosate ça revient à poser un
boulet à l'agriculture française
en fait c'est pour ça que je dis que la
voix pour l'interdiction du glyphosate
doit être au niveau européen il faut
qu'on interdise tous ensemble parce que
si on l'interdît qu'en france d'abord il
ya 40%
c'est un boulot but quand même la fns là
il doit quand même faire si on prend le
temps il ya 40% des fruits et légumes
qu'on mange en france qui viennent de
l'étranger principalement d'europe lors
des fruits tropicaux on va dire donc ce
qui veut dire que l'on va moins produire
en france parce qu'on aura plus vif aux
autres donc nos agriculteurs votre en
difficulté donc on va plus à porter
à l'étranger donc on va manger autant
que l'ifo that et en plus on faire
mourir nos agriculteurs donc si vous
voulez un moment ont peur des grands
principes et se dire ils font un
terrible il faut at on peut aussi être
réaliste et se dire qu'il faut
l'interdire oui ou non au niveau
européen et froideur que c'est la
réponse du gouvernement
une fois n'est pas coutume je suis
d'accord avec le gouvernement l'a su
vous vous avez voté donc contre le
glyphosate est ce que vous aviez
soupçonner que la fnsea était un lobby
aussi puissant est-ce qu'il ya autant de
lobby puissant à l'assemblée nationale
qu'on le dit c'est vrai que j'ai
découvert je savais qu'il y avait des
lobbys comme comme il ya deux bouquins
était déjà dans la politique avant ils
savaient oui il savait un peu vous vous
l'avez découvert vous avez été surprise
oui j'ai découvert qu'il y avait des
lobbys mais vous savez lobby aujourd'hui
c'est un gros mot on pourrait presque
penser que c'est un gros mot parce que
dans l'opinion publique c'est
extrêmement mal perçue mais en fait
et à chaque fois qu'on est un groupe de
défense d'intérêts voilà mais à chaque
fois qu on rencontre quelqu'un c'est
presque un représentant d'une
association etc
c'est du lobby quelque part c'est normal
de défendre ses intérêts après il ya
défendre ses intérêts et 1
et défendre ses intérêts il ya vraiment
plusieurs façons de faire et c'est vrai
que parfois il y en a qui sont un petit
peut-être un petit peu plus agressif que
d'autres je parle pas forcément de la
fnsea ils ont des intérêts à défendre il
est lyonnais goût des moyens financiers
j'entends y voyait un daaf voilà donc
j'entends leurs problématiques
moi il me semble qu'on a déjà des
alternatives qui pourraient être mises
en place et je pense qu'on peut encore
développer d'autres alternatives je
manque d'une commission d' enquête sur
l'alimentation industrielle en
auditionne régulièrement l'inra le cnrs
ou suivre et et je pense qu'on peut tout
à fait y pousser en trois ans est arrivé
en trois une petite question pour vous
il ya le bouquin vous est aussi
secrétaire départemental des
républicains dans le territoire de
belfort les républicains vous avez
vraiment du mal à exister dans
l'opposition derrière deux poids lourds
front national et la france a soulevé
crois que ça dépend ceux qui
s'intéressent vraiment débat
parlementaire se rendre compte qu'on est
de loin le premier groupe d'opposition à
la je prends le moi je reviens dans le
logement
on est très clairement ce qui avons le
plus défendu d'arguments face à ceux du
gouvernement et des des arguments se
tient debout le très constructif qui se
voit pas forcément ça allait dire non
pas du tout des arguments objectifs pour
dire quand on est d'accord et quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec le gouvernement
alors après vous avez deux postures la
porte et les postures de monsieur
mélenchon et madame le pen qui sont
contre tout et tous contre j'ai envie de
dire d'accord et qu'on m'aime beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup en avant alors
monsieur mélenchon je trouve qu'il est
présent l'assemblée donc ça me pose pas
de souci effectivement il en profite il
profite de sa tribune madame le pen qui
n'est jamais là il ya toujours un média
pour l'interviewer pour faire croire
qu'elle est raide pour qu'elle dise des
choses alors il ya aussi le poids
médiatique qu'on leur donne et c'est
vrai que nous le défaut qu'on a
peut-être c'est que notre président
laurent wauquiez n'est pas député donc
on va beaucoup monsieur mélenchon de
l'âme le pen voit moins les pois venir y
rester moi moi du nil dans cette
émission dans quatre ans qu'est ce qui
fera que vous pourriez dire mon mandat
est réussie mandat sera réussie si les
citoyens du territoire de belfort qui
m'ont fait confiance en juin dernier
sont fiers de m'avoir eu comme
représentants et pense que j'ai défendu
correctement leurs intérêts les intérêts
du pays cette même question pour vous
fans et janvier dans quatre ans ce
serait quoi un mandat réussi pour vous
mais mal de la même façon c'est vrai que
la reconnaissance de ceux qui nous ont
élus est extrêmement importante et moi
j'irai en plus que si on arrive à sortir
la france de l'immobilisme et
l'attentisme dans lequel elle c'était un
petit peu conforté on aura gagné en aura
marre et vous irez plus sur eux sur le
terrain peut-être plus que ce que je
suis je suis je suis sûr et vous méritez
peut-être à être connue finalement en
fait à surnommer chaussures je sais les
gens suivront les électeurs vous réglez
les acteurs de la vie économique et
associative vous réclamerez tous ceux
qui m'écrivent pour me pour demander à
me rencontrer je les rencontre donc je
les invite à ce moment-là ce à se
signaler et j'irai avec plaisir à leur
rencontre comme je le fais depuis le
début dans quatre ans vous vous
représentez peut-être pas où ce sera
juste un feu de paille fanette chervier
donc alors moi j'avais pris un
engagement très clair quand je m'étais
présenté j'estimais que l'engagement
citoyen que je prenais c'est un
engagement pour cinq ans qui
s'inscrivait dans le renouvellement et
donc j'avais précisé que je ne me
représenterai pas donc je fais cinq ans
et je laisse ensuite ma place à
quelqu'un j'espère ainsi pas les engager
merci beaucoup madame merci monsieur
merci de votre attention et puis bon
dimanche après midi à tous merci au
revoir